λμό του κόσμο τάξει εντιλεβάνε σ είναι λίγο δύσκολο να μιλο για με ένα και
να πω ότι θεωρώ όμως ότι ανμτα ο πήρας δεν αλλά ξε ποτέ αυτό που
ήταν έαπαιδί να από τον κόσμό ότι μια αυτωχίνικο γένειπαδί μου έρωσε σε αν προσφιγούν
ιγισμόν το οποίο είμαι πάντα στον κόσμο και είμαι πάντα τον κόσμ δεν έχω λλάξι
ις συνήθιες μου δεν έχω αλλαξι ν από ότι έχεινα κάτι τώρα πουμου πόπου δεν
πρέπει να στυν αναστρέφουμε με τον απλον κόσμον αντιθέρως είναι και το ξεγόνοο αυτό το
πράγμα πέραν από την προσωπική μου ζωή πούμε συνέχειας στον κόσμο είναι ότι πλέον και
θες μοθετημένος δημοτικς συμβούλιο κάθε εβδομάδα κάθε δίο βδώμαδες γρίζουμε οι γειτονιές όλις τη λαρνακας
απόότη πρώτη ηγειτονία μεχριν τελευταία γειτονα ορόκλινη λιβάδια ίνοικισμούς ικέ θες μοθετημένα πέραν από το
γεγονος τις προσωπικής μας ζωής είναι ότι τουράχις τομια φρανι εβδόματα θα πάμε εμια συνικί
αν ενωρίαν τις λάρνακας να να ακούσουμε τον κόσμον επιτόπου και ναδούμε επιτόπου α προβλήματα
περίμενες δημάρχε στις τελευταίς εκλογές κάποιο μα συνοβήνας ενώ μαγάριο τις λάρναγα διαδή ταντόσει αποδόχει
από τους πολίτες που διάφορο κομματικά συνολά ημόνο το κόμμα προ έρχεσαι περίμενες το ττομοταξι
αντιλαβάνεσε κατάτη διάρκειαν της ιδίας μορις πρόη θεν κιου θα την ακάποιο του κόσμοξεβάθυμο που
κάποιο να ότι ν κατεβαίνειοτάδειοτάδε για τ ελιε θεωρώ ότιήταν μια συλλογική δουλια ότι καταφέραμε
στέλα να κανε πρώτη θητί αστηλλογικά όλες ι δομάδες όλι φορίς τις πόλης να νωθούμε
να πετύχουμε κάποιουυς στόχους άρα θεωρώ ήταν μια φυσική εξέλεξη της ζουλειας την οποία ν
έγινε την πρώτη η θυτίαν και το γεγόνος ότι ηλάννα κα προερχότεν από μια δύσκολη
καρασταση γνωστά τα γεγόντα πληγομένον τοδημοτικό στυμβολιον πλικονος ο κόσμος τηλλά να κς ότι καταφέραμε
κάποιους τόχους την πρώτη φθύτια βοήθεισε να κριβώς σε αυτό το λήμα αλλά που δεν
ήταν δεδομενο για μέαδιαδή καις τις εκλογίες αλλά ιδεν έυχισι χάςτες τό το κλίμα αντιθέλς
πρέπει από δεικνής καθημερα σε αυτό τον κόσμο και γεμείς τις με περισότεριν ευθύνη γιατί